Scientists claim that the earth’s magnetic
poles will reverse within the next few thousand
years.
So why does that happen?
And what exactly does it mean for us?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and something
that’s always fascinated me, is the earth’s
magnetic field.
Maybe it’s because we can’t see it with
our own eyes, so it’s this elusive thing
that we pretty much assume to be constant.
Believe it or not though, the north and south
poles we know today, weren’t always that
way.
786,000 years ago - the earth’s magnetic
field flipped - and it’s remained constant
ever since.
But before that happened, south was actually
north - and what we now know as north, was
south.
According to scientists, every half million
years or so - the earth’s dipole magnetic
field, which you can imagine like a bar magnet
with a north end and a south end, starts to
weaken, before eventually reversing completely.
No one is really sure why it happens, but
it’s thought to be caused by changes in
the fluid portion of the earth’s iron core.
Up until recently, scientists presumed this
reversal process took a few thousand years
- but new evidence suggests that the most
recent major reversal 786,000 years ago - actually
happened in less than 100 years - roughly
the span of a single lifetime.
Obviously, flips like this have occurred several
times throughout Earth’s history.
But the next one, scientists say, may happen
within the next few thousand years.
New evidence indicates that the intensity
of the Earth’s magnetic field is decreasing
at a rate 10 times faster than normal, leading
many geophysicists to believe that we’re
on the brink of another reversal.
So what would happen if that did occur?
Would there be any noticeable changes?
Well, the good news is - there are no documented
catastrophes associated with past reversals.
So you shouldn’t expect the human race to
immediately die out.
But that doesn’t mean nothing bad could
happen.
A magnetic reversal would almost surely wreak
havoc on our electrical grid, which could
potentially bring it down.
It would also make us vulnerable to energetic
particles from the sun and cosmic rays - both
of which can cause genetic mutations.
And that could happen before the reversal
even takes place.
Like I described earlier, there’s a period
prior to reversals where the magnetic field
gets progressively weaker, and the genetic
mutations that arise from that, could potentially
increase cancer rates.
So the longer it takes for that reversal process
to complete, the more harmful it would be
to us.
Also worth mentioning, is the fact that even
though the last reversal only took 100 years
- it was preceded by a period of magnetic
instability that spanned over 6,000 years.
Meaning if the next reversal happens within
a few thousand years, we could start seeing
the effects of it - very soon.
Kinda scary to think about it.
But at the same time - it’s not likely that
any of this will affect us in our lifetime.
So, before you start packing up your family
and moving off the grid, Doomsday Preppers-style,
just remember that.
It’s probably not worth it.
What do you guys think though, are you worried
about this?
You can lay it all out for us in the comments
right down there - or if you wanna get in
touch with me on Twitter, you can do so at
@TaraLongest.
That’s it for me, but as always - thank
you guys for watching.